because she worked in restaurants you oh
yeah oh yeah so you worked in Hawaii but
then you worked in LA as well yes I
worked in at a restaurant in Beverly
Hills to pause it was what tried to be
it was a look it was a terrible
restaurant and and it was it was just
awful and I was a major contributing
factor it was it had it was just real
garbage it's been revamped now but I
loved it it was the name I'll give you
free meals I mean they will give me
that's how I ate I mean when you're when
you're in Hollywood and in other places
like you need a job that gives you four
days free so you can try to audition for
projects so I'd work the weekends I'd
worked the nights and now that's all I
did had no money and no one was coming
to the restaurant so I wasn't making any
tip I'd make like 20 or 30 bucks a day
maybe and so it was really a place I'd
go to nourishment to eat yeah yeah
that kitchen fed me for like the time
that I was there Isis oh man you ever do
this where you I would like a lady would
come in and she'd be like what do you
recommend I'm like 32 ounce porterhouse
we should tell them I said listen here's
how you want medium-rare with some
mushrooms on the side I get you some
mashed potatoes they're gonna love this
you know 90 year old woman and so I
bring the stake out to this lady she I'm
not I'm not hiding in the corner
watching like and she tells like how
much is she eating and how much do I get
you know go back and she was like I
can't eat another bite 80% of the steak
is left
we always thing called the tunnel which
is an area between the dining room in
the kitchen where they keep all the soft
drinks and like the silverware and stuff
and that's I've been busted so many
times eating off people's plates that
they were like you have to stop doing
that like it's really really bad
and I so anything I ate I had to eat in
the tunnel this is my safe zone where
for judgment the customers are going to
see me eat their food and the chef's not
gonna yell at me for eating the food so
I was like I had about 14 maybe ounces
of steak that I had to get down in about
ten feet straight up like swabbo toe
dragon on wolf the steak down you know
get it oh my god
cha-cha-cha that's like three days worth
of protein right
walk back yell and the lady was like
listen I'd love to get that steak to go
oh gosh ma'am let me get you I'll go
check and I was like Oh what do i do
what do I do
and I said I'm so I'm so sorry I already
threw in the trash I threw in the trash
she said it's for my dog it's fine
just fish it if you don't mind just fish
it out put it in a boxes I was like you
bet you bet yeah yes ma'am
absolutely will do I'm not walking like
Freddy on the fly man don't ask any
questions just give me one right now and
so he started cooking at stake and I was
like in terms of [__] I went out to
where I was like ma'am I'm gonna get you
that steak they just took the garbage
out to the dumpster I'm gonna roll up my
sleeves i'ma jump in that dumpster I'm
gonna get it for you because I'm gonna
dog Pomeranian no way I love that so
this week ready where's that steak and
she ended up being so like happy that I
would be willing to dig through the
garbage for her dog that she gave me a
giant tip and she left early cuz she
couldn't wait for the steak to be done
so I got another snake and like Graham
Norton here if you'd like to see even
more stuff like that then hit subscribe
or don't it's a free world but I know
what I do in that situation